ça vous dirait d'être une bonne personne
ça vous dirait d'aider quelqu'un qui se
sent seul juste comme ça en 5 minutes
avec votre téléphone ou votre ordinateur
bon je vous propose un truc j'espère que
ça va vous parler est-ce que vous vous
êtes déjà senti seul pas ouf hein et ben
l'association APF France handicap a une
opération pour lutter contre l'isolement
des personnes en situation de handicap
ça s'appelle les bus solidaires c'est
des bus qui vont dans les villes dans
les villages à la campagne et cetera
pour rencontrer des personnes en
situation de handicap isolé parce que
souvent handicap et ruralité ça rime
avec isolement ok non ça rime pas après
j'ai dit que j'étais Verline non plus
vous pouvez participer hyper facilement
je vous explique vous allez sur
écrire.apf-francehandicap.org et vous
écrivez un petit mot une blague une
histoire cool un petit texte sympa des
conseils de film ou de chanson feelg une
recette à vous comme vous voulez et avec
les équipes de l'association on s'occupe
de leur apporter ça oui parce que j'y
vais avec eux dans le bus et tout et je
reviens vous parler de tout ça en vidéo
fin novembre ça vous va à vous ça va
vous prendre 5 minutes mais les
personnes qui vont lire tous vos
messages ça va leur faire leur journée
minimum allez je compte sur vous